so one of the big reasons why we chose  to do a Kickstarter the quality level  that we have today on the game is at a  very high wall and we want to make it  just a little bit higher we want to push  that level of Polish so it's something  that we can be proud of as game  developer to you as a gamer can love to  play we really want to reward our  Kickstarter backers in addition to  obviously the copy of the game that  should be pre-ordered  you're going to receive selectable  unlocks that you get to choose how to  outfit your mech and a very special play  on the higher tiers what we really  wanted to have people be able to do is  get involved and put some of their  personality in their character into the  creation of unique skins and unique  enemies it's really the heart and soul  of what we think Kickstarter is about  what's better in the robot arroba the  changes in to attack